[Arabic recitation]
in al-Wajiz
in the chapters regarding
the timings of prayers. We've discussed
it. We've discussed the
various timings of each of the five
prayers.
idealic times for each of the five
prayers, and we also discussed the
absolute end of the timings for each of
the five prayers, the beginning times
and the end times.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam would
often pray Zuhr
once the sun had
started to
get closer to Asr time. And the reason
for this is because of the intensity of
heat, especially during the summer time.
So, during the summer months instead of
having people come to Salat al-Zuhr when
the sun is at its highest and when the
sun is at its
hottest, he would wait closer to Asr
time, about a about an hour after until
the sun would cool off a little bit
before people would come out to the
masjid. This is still a sunnah that is
enacted, but it is
a lot more
necessary
in a masjid that doesn't have air
conditioning, for instance.
people mostly walk to the masjid
rather than drive
and so forth. This is really the
reasoning for this and this is the time
when it would be appropriate
to
exercise this sunnah. So, if for
instance, we were in an area where
people walk to Zuhr or in an area where
in certain masajid around the world,
probably most masajid around the world,
they don't have AC in a desert area, it
becomes extremely stifling hot inside of
the masjid, so it becomes the sunnah to
let it cool off a bit before starting
salah. And the reason for this is so
that a person can have a degree of
comfort in
salah. Especially, you know, it's hot
out and then everybody's coming
together, standing close together,
usually in a smaller masjid. It gets
very hot, very uncomfortable. And so, it
is
the prophet salallahu alayhi wasallam,
he enacted this sunnah for this purpose.
And so, if this
necessity arises, we implement the
sunnah. If it's not, then
the best time to make zuhr is at the
beginning of its time.
[Arabic recitation]
the narration of Jabir ibn Samurah
is regarding praying zuhr as soon as
zuhr comes in, immediately. The next
narration, the narration of Abu
Hurairah, is going to be
waiting for zuhr until it gets late and
closer to asr. When do we enact each of
these? Based on the
heat. This is This is the whole reason.
So, we have narration of Jabir ibn
Samurah where he makes salat al-zuhr as
soon as it comes in. Then we have the
next narration, the narration of Abu
Hurairah, where he makes salat al-zuhr
much closer to asr. Yaqulu
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam says,
"If it becomes very hot outside, then
delay prayer until it becomes cooler
because indeed the intensity of the heat
of the daytime is from the gusts of
Jahannam." And the point of this is that
anytime when we have an extreme
that occurs for Jama' salah, it is the
sunnah to await that extreme to go away.
to the point that even if
there is a need to join prayers
in Jama', then this is something
that is enacted in extreme cold, extreme
heat, extreme
rain, extreme ice, etc. And we'll get
to that in the future chapters.
But the point of these narrations is
that extreme heat, out of the ordinary
heat, even recurring heat,
then
we are to delay prayer to where it
becomes more comfortable to pray. We can
becomes more comfortable to pray.
Not necessarily comfortable. There's
only so much you can do, but delaying
prayer, especially for those who walk
to salah during the middle of the day
[Arabic recitation]